according to legend a huntsman once
tracked a lion that was terrorizing his
village all the way to its den
though armed with only a spear the man
managed to kill both the lion and its
mate but spared the cubs
this mercy so pleased the old gods that
they send a shaft of sunlight deep into
the cave gleaming off golden walls
the hunter became a miner and built a
ring for to guard his new wealth
nobody ever asks what happened to the
cops maybe the gods forgot about them
and they staffed
maybe there never were any cops alliance
a hunter doesn't matter
someone found enough gold in that cave
to buy whatever truth he wanted
along with a castle that he'd name after
his new family
casterly rock
thanks to that gold casterly rock soon
became the largest wealthiest and best
defended castle in westeros an army that
struggled up the main approach would
still have to climb thick high and well
defended walls
should they choose instead to lay siege
the sea helpfully carved a massive cave
beneath the castle which over time
became a private port complete with
docks wharfs and shipyards
and so to this day even with all the
golden westeros to tempt invaders
casterly rock
has never fallen
at least not in battle the castle is
sadly all that remains of its namesake
family the castilies
according to another legend my ancestor
landed clever swindled the castle from
them the most common story is that he
found a hidden cleft in the rock and
snuck into the castle
at night he whispered threats into
sleeping ears howled in the darkness
planted one brother's treasures in the
room of another and so forth
by the end of his games the castles
believed the demon was haunting their
home and fled
my brother prefers a different version
landa clever
did find a secret entrance into the rock
but used it to have his way with the
casterly maidens eventually the girls
gave birth to golden-haired bastards and
the casterlies had no choice but to
accept their father into the family
in gratitude he changed the family name
to honor himself and house lannister was
born
the casterlys used the gold of the rocks
to become lords
the lannisters became kings
for thousands of years the kingdom of
the rock ruled the westerlands
when the ironborn became a nuisance my
ancestors sailed to the iron islands and
returned with a hundred ironborn
hostages promising to hang one from the
rock every time the ironborn dared radar
shores the ironborn stayed away well
after 20 or so
when the andals arrived after sweeping
across the rest of westeros we invited
their sons and daughters into the rock
as squires and court ladies i don't
think we ever had to hang any of them
finally aegon the conqueror defeated us
on the field of fire and my ancestor
knelt
still
little changed but titles and taxes for
when visenya targaryen saw the rock she
gave thanks that my ancestor had met
aegon in the field
even dragonflame would have washed over
the castle like the waves and left just
as much a mark
when disciplining unruly vassals most
lords sent armies my father tywin
only had to send a singer
there's no faster way to dollar vassal's
ambition or any festive occasion
than hearing the reigns of castamere
how's reign of customer was an old and
proud house that was slowly sinking back
into the mug
their minds had run dry
without gold they turned to a more
common source of wealth
daughters
lady ellen rain was betrothed to my
great uncle but when he fell in battle
lady ellen saw comfort in his twin
brother's bed
beating out the other woman he promised
to marry
then the husband who had shared his
twin's wife shared his twins death on a
different battlefield
lady ellen flung herself at the new
and married heir to the rock
but my grandfather titus was more kitten
than lion
he ran away and told his wife of lady
ellen's designs and lady ellen soon
found herself married off to walter and
tarbik lord of another failing house
the reigns and tarpox should have sunk
into obscurity together and they would
have if not for my grandfather becoming
lord of casterly rock
at first the westerlands laughed with
the laughing lion as the jovial titus
was called but when men realized this
lion had neither teeth nor claws
he started to laugh at him
loved harder than the reigns and tarpox
though lady ellen was no longer welcome
at casterly rock titus didn't refuse her
brothers roger and reynard rayne
not even when they asked for extravagant
loans
thanks to our family's gold lady ellen
restored topic hall to a splendor she
had known since being cast out of our
home
when my grandfather broached the subject
of repayment roger and reynard only
laughed
and soon enough my grandfather was
laughing along with them
then my father tywin returned from the
war of the nine penny kings where he'd
seen how the rest of the realm sniggered
at house lannister
determined to restore our proper place
my father demanded the immediate
repayment of all deaths to the rock or a
hostage from those who couldn't pay
reynard reign merely laughed when he
received the raven
lord walder and tarbek chose to ride to
casterly rock sure that he could cow
lord titus into rescinding my father's
commands
he could have except it wasn't titus who
met him at the gates but my father who
had lord walderman thrown into a dungeon
lady ellen protested the reigns
threatened war and finally my
grandfather broke and released lord
tarbik with an apology no less
as if bathing himself in shame titus
further forgave all the tarpic deaths to
our house
to celebrate the end of hostilities lord
roger feasted titus at castamere and the
two lords proclaimed their friendship
for eternity
my father allowed eternity
to last a year
when he summoned the reigns and tarpox
to casterly rock to answer for their
crimes they rose and revolt
exactly as he expected
their defiance gave him a pretext to
call his banners and ride for target
hall and castaney with an army behind
him he didn't even bother to inform my
grandfather
my father's army descended on the tablet
so quickly that lord waldron had no time
to gather his forces and rode against my
father with only his household nights
soon his head his son's heads and the
heads of any man with tarpic blood
adorned the spears of the lannister
vanguard as it marched to tarmac hall
at their approach lady ellen tarby
closed the gates and sent ravens to her
brothers at customy
she assumed they'd have more than enough
time to muster their armies and break
what would be a long siege
my father had trepuchets up in a day
and brought down the keep within hours
lady ellen and her son were crushed in
its fall
when the tarbic forces surrendered
my father put their castle to the torch
roger rain arrived with his army just in
time to see the flames consuming his
sister's home
he charged my father's camp hoping
surprise would win out over my father's
great numbers
it didn't
with half his men dead on the field and
a crossball in his back
lord roger fled back to castamere
the lannister host arrived at castamere
three days later
like casterly rock the seed of house
rain had begun as a mine when the gold
cave out the mine shafts were widened
into halls galleries and bed chambers
deep beneath the earth
the rain brothers didn't have the men to
defend the castle walls and retreated
into their underground stronghold
from this relative safety they offered
terms to my father to avoid a long siege
my father didn't reply
instead he commanded that the mines be
sealed with stone and soil until there
was no way in and no way out
when that was completed it took less
than a day to damn the stream beside the
castle and only two to divert it to the
nearest mine entrance
the reigns had taken more than 300 men
women and children into the mines
a few guards reported hearing faint
screams and shouts below them one night
but come dawn the earth was silent once
again
and now the rain weeps over the halls
with no one left to hear
on the far western coast of the
continent high atop a rocky promontory
overlooking the sunset sea sits casterly
rock
ancestral seat of house lannister
below it lies lannis port one of the
great cities of westeros a center for
trade
culture
and the great lannister fleet
there are a number of gold and silver
mines in the westerlands
making it the richest region in all of
westeros
one of the most productive mines lies
beneath casterly rock itself
making house lannister the wealthiest of
all the noble houses
this allows house lannister to finance
many endeavors of other noble houses
even the king himself has sought credit
from casterly rock from time to time
we lannisters claim our descent from the
andal invaders and through the female
bloodline land the clever
according to the legend lan using only
his wits one casterly rock from the
noble house of casterly during the age
of heroes
the lannisters reigned as kings of the
rock for thousands of years
and worked to make it the envy of the
rest of the seven kingdoms
our time as kings ended however when
aegon targaryen otherwise known as aegon
the conqueror arrived in westeros with
his army
the last king of the rock king loren
lannister joined forces with king mern
gardner the king of the reach
together with sixty thousand men they
met the targaryen host in open battle
history tells us that aegon unleashed
all three of his dragons slaughtering
four thousand men at what came to be
known as the field of fire
kingman himself was burned alive that
day and house gardener turned to ash
with him
seeing both the threat and opportunity
the targaryens represented
lauren wisely surrendered and aided
aegon in his further conquest of
westeros
the lannisters were thus appointed lords
paramount of the westerlands and wardens
of the west
titles we hold to this day
let us be clear though it is neither
luck nor royal favor that makes our
house prosperous
there have been times in our history
where some have thought us weak
lazy or opulent
my father titus lannister nearly
bankrupted our house with his poor
investments
and allowed himself to be mocked openly
at court
when our vassal the reigns of castimere
dared to rise up against the lannisters
they learned how dangerous it can be to
taunt a lion
i tywin lannister led the assault on
castamere to put down this rebellion
i made an example of them to anyone who
doubts our might
they even made a quaint song about the
fates of the reigns of castamere
sadly there are no reigns left to hear
it
today the golden lion of lannister is
rightly admired and feared throughout
the seven kingdoms
our words are
hear me roar
but there are other words that should be
remembered when crossing a lion of
casterly rock
a lannister always pays his debts